on a vu que jean luc lemoine à l'arrivée
de françois j'ai envoyé un petit message
à jean luc il sera dans samedi dans rien
tous les jours à 13 14 heures ce sera le
samedi à 14h sur france tellement place
les grands du rire nikos aliagas qui te
repas ou des napolitains fotos aliagas
qui te repas leur union et sur europe 1
il n'y aura plus tard ils vont faire
tous les trucs en interne maintenant
voilà il vole plus du tout dépenser
d'argent sur la grille voilà donc il y
aura c'est ça va être
c'est à chaque l'affairé ont réduit les
coûts en général dessous on réduit
laquelle on leur crée une ambiance
haussier cessera de la rédaction ils
veulent recréer une adresse faire une
âme
j'ai maintenant dans l'hélico mais je
vous dis je vous dire la vérité nikos
c'est un animateur de divertissement la
matinale d'europe 1 ça reste quand même
un truc sur zinfos moi mon père il a
rien d'une fraude à nikos moi j'irai et
je le trouve été très bon dans
l'exercice mais mon père qui qui se la
raconte
ouais rien qui soit un vrai il me dit
moi je l'écouterai jamais nico ce matin
un journaliste accrédité la raison mon
père voilà c'est un niveau des niveaux
des infos méric nico je peux faire tous
les efforts qu'on veut malheureusement
quand à une éthique l égide est mort le
jour il interviewait macron c'est
horrible interview était bonne mais tu
avais en tête qu'il avait interviewé
mariah carey dans sa grotte du d'inside
la veille donc effectivement il ya un
croisé et qui reste karl zéro l'après
midi 15-0 le premier je ne sais pas à
une colle pour une fois tu crois pas je
crois pas ah bon je crois pas je pense
que tout le monde va avantage en
remportant l'émission et du corps lui
apprend que vous avez vu que stupéfiant
va s'arrêter 11,2 voilà l'émission
marchait pas du tout daphné bürki qui te
prodige en fait qu'ils arrêtent de
prodige pour prendre anne marie sophie
écoutez il ya mallaury nataf non oui
elle est de retour sur les plateaux
d'avé production on la retrouvera au
casting des mystères de l'amour
voilà je vous donne les infos du
jugement à ce programme nous rejoignent
et à 21h face beaucoup beaucoup de
choses